ми маємо допомогти українцям та
гарантувати їм виживання Цієї зими
60-70% повітряних об'єктів російської
армії успішно відбуваються ЗСУ зокрема і
завдяки німецькій військовій підтримці
Голодомор - це злочин про який відносно
мало знають у Німеччині будь-які заклики
до припинення вогню нині легковажні або
не президент те що ми Нині спостерігаємо
в Україні Матя мало спільного із
загальноприйнятими методами ведення
війни те що відбувається це війна проти
мирного населення чому Путін так вчиняє
І що це змінює для нас
Я не зовсім згоден з тим що це не має
стосунку до війни Я думаю що це власне
частина військової стратегії Росії
це не лише жорстока війна що ведеться
проти Української армії а й жорстока
атака на критично важливу інфраструктуру
І звісно на цивільне населення
стає дедалі помітнішим із наближенням
зими
ми знаємо що через руйнування газової та
енергетичної інфраструктури люди в
Україні змушені зіткнутися з темрявою та
Холодом і це не випадковий побічний
ефект а схоже справді мета російських
атак і частина Російської стратегії
спрямованої на завдання ударів по
цивільному населенню щоб виснажити
країну
ми маємо протистояти цьому Ми маємо
допомогти українцям та гарантувати їм
виживання Цієї зими
Німеччина допомагає Україні постачанням
зброї але Київ все що чекає на бойові
Танки які Берлін відправляє в Україну чи
війна проти цивільного населення не є
приводом переосмислити німецьку політику
у цьому питанні
Я вважаю що позиція Німеччини у цьому
контексті змінилася І це стосується не
лише уряду а й усього населення яке за
кілька місяців зрозуміло те до чого ми
звикли в плані безпеки в Європі більше
не гарантовано у результаті уряд ФРН
ухвалив рішення про величезні додаткові
витрати на оборону включаючи найкраще
оснащення та екіпірування бундесверу і
ми тепер справді підтримуємо Україну не
лише гуманітарно фінансово та економічно
а й значною мірою у військовому плані Як
ви знаєте я був в Україні і можу лише
підтвердити що з одного боку наявна
раніше критика німецької військової
підтримки вщухла А на її місці з'явилась
натомість велика вдячність і На мою
думку німецький уряд зробив ставку на
правильну підтримку України коли я там
був повітряна тривога лунала щодня і
люди були змушені терпляче чекати в
бомбосховищах тож правильно було зробити
акцент саме на протиповітряній обороні
на захисті від Дронів та передусім ракет
зараз допомагає українським містам і
громадам захищатися наскільки це тільки
можливо це не відбувається в повному
обсязі але 60-70% повітряних об'єктів
російської армії успішно відбуваються
ЗСУ зокрема і завдяки німецькій
військовій підтримці
Україна нещодавно вшанувала пам'ять
мільйонів жертв голодомору президент
Зеленський порівнює Голодомору у 1930-ті
роки з тим що відбувається сьогодні чи
чинить Путін геноцид в Україні
Голодомор - це злочин про який відносно
мало знають у Німеччині але ми маємо
пам'ятати що його жертвою стала зокрема
Україна і голод не був результатом не
врожаю як це стверджували впродовж
багатьох десятиліть передусім російській
історики Це була навмисна стратегія
сталінського режиму змусити голодувати
частину населення тодішнього Радянського
Союзу
1932-33 року щоб зробити їх покірними Я
дуже вдячний німецькому бундестагу за те
що цього тижня він скористався нагодою
вшанувати цій події та цю трагедію
ви знаєте розпалювачів війни у Москві
Путін відкрито говорив про свої наміри
щодо України протягом багатьох років
раніше керівництво Німеччини і ви
зокрема не сприймали це всерйоз А зараз
як бути з погрозами Путіна застосувати
ядерну зброю
по-перше Я би посперечався з тим що це
не сприймалося всерйоз якщо подивитися
на період після 2014 року європейські
уряди намагалися не тільки зберегти
режим припинення вогню але її
використовували його як Пролог до миру
З цією метою було підписано Мінський
угоди які ми обговорювали з тодішнім
президентом України Порошенком і ви як і
я пам'ятаєте незліченні спроби досягти
прогресу в переговорах у рамках
нормандського формату разом із Францією
Україною та Росією по-друге щодо загрози
з боку Росії застосувати ядерну зброю це
неприпустимо адже зараз робляться спроби
щоб позбутися ядерної зброї в усьому
світі
загроза застосування ядерної зброї не
тільки не виправдана а й фактично
суперечить нашому історичному досвіду це
неприпустимо і це буде наступний ступінь
ескалації у цій війні боку Росії ядерна
зброя не повинна застосовуватися Я думаю
що такої думки дотримується більшість у
всьому світі переговори великої
двадцятки на балі це в чергове
продемонстрували адже там Одноголосно
засудили погрози І звісно тим більше
застосування ядерної зброї чіткий сигнал
який Сподіваюся зрозуміють у Москві
які шляхи виходу з цієї війни ви бачите
як може виглядати рішення прийнятне для
обох сторін
будь-які заклики до припинення вогню
нині легковажні тому що перемир'я в цей
момент означало б по суті визнання
несправедливості що вже відбулася
припинення вогню означатиме що Росія
залишить собі окуповані території це
позначало що Росія залишає за собою
окуповану територію а значить буде
схвалено порушення кордонів нехтування
міжнародним правом та захоплення
території
це не може бути сенсом режиму припинення
вогню тож на жаль на даний момент я поки
що не бачу виходу
вимагає гарантії безпеки передусім від
Німеччини перше ніж говоритиме про
переговори чи може Україна розраховувати
на це
this
очікування України добре відомі і
федеральному урядові ФРН і є сигнали не
тільки з Німеччини що такі гарантії
безпеки можуть бути надані але ми все ще
на тому етапі коли не можемо точно
сказати як можуть виглядати такі
гарантії безпеки хто їх надаватиме і
яким має бути їхні зміст тому що зміст
таких гарантій пов’язаний із закінченням
війни а оскільки кінця війни поки не
видно то й гарантії безпеки поки що не
можуть бути сформульовані
яка недавнього влучання ракети по
території Польщі Наскільки Ви стурбовані
тим що війна Яка ведеться в Україні
прийде і до нас конт
Я дуже сподіваюся що цього можна
уникнути і моя надія зміцнилася після
дуже обережної реакції яку
продемонстрували не лише США а й НАТО
загалом між американськими польським
президентом було тісне спілкування
відразу після того що сталося на сході
Польщі
негайно відреагував генеральний секретар
НАТО який зазначив що спочатку треба
розслідувати ситуацію а потім робити
висновки Я вважаю що це свідчить про
розсудливість країн НАТО а також
наявність мінімальних контактів з
Москвою на військовому рівні там де такі
контакти існують вони мають
використовуватись з обох сторін